This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I want to start with a letter. And this is reporter Matthew Kielty. This is a letter that got sent out to a couple hundred people back in 1990. So Roman, if you have a letter and mine. Yeah, sure, sure. Dear so-and-so, the safe disposal of nuclear waste is one of the most pressing issues facing the United States today.
这里是“99%无形”(99% Invisible)。我是罗曼·马斯(Roman Mars)。我想从一封信开始。这位是记者马修·基尔蒂(Matthew Kielty)。这是一封在1990年左右寄给几百人的信。罗曼，如果你有一封信，我也有。对，当然，当然。致某某阁下，安全处置核废料是当今美国面临的最紧迫问题之一。
It totally is. But if you actually, if you skip down past that, there's, I mean, that's just about how there's these people. We're planning on bearing a bunch of nuclear waste out in the New Mexico desert at this place called the Waste Isolation Pilot Plant. But if you go down like another paragraph. You have been nominated to participate in a study sponsored by Sandia National Laboratories that will identify what kinds of markers should be placed at the WIPP site.
确实如此。但如果你实际往下看，我的意思是，这只是关于有这样一群人。我们正计划将一堆核废料埋在新墨西哥州的沙漠中，在一个叫作“废物隔离试点厂”(Waste Isolation Pilot Plant)的地方。但如果你再往下看一个段落。你已被提名参与一项由桑迪亚国家实验室(Sandia National Laboratories)赞助的研究，该研究将确定应该在WIPP址设立什么样的标记。
Yeah, just jump down a little bit further. And to develop a marker system that will remain operational during the performance period of the site. 10,000 years. There it is. There it is. That is the part that I love. I had a moment of wondering if it was a joke. This is John Lombard. He received one of these letters, which makes sense given his line of work. I'm an artist and I work on projects involving
对，再往下跳一点。并建立一个在场地的效力期间内保持运作的标记系统。一万年。就是这样。就是这样。这就是我最喜欢的部分。我曾一度怀疑这到底是不是个玩笑。这位是约翰·隆堡(John Lombard)。他收到了其中一封信，考虑到他的职业，这倒也合情合理。我是一名艺术家，我从事涉及
unusual communication problems. The dude spent time in the 70s working with Carl Sagan and Andrew and on the Voyager Golden Record. One of NASA's attempts at communicating with aliens. So you think this sort of thing would be right in his wheelhouse. Usually you don't get asked to design something that's gonna last 10 thousand years. That's twice the span of recorded human history. The federal government really was calling on him to help protect people 10,000 years in the future. The Waste Isolation Pilot Plant, WIPP, or WIPP for short, was ordered into existence
寻常沟通问题的项目。这家伙在70年代曾与卡尔·萨根(Carl Sagan)和安德鲁合作，参与“旅行者号”金唱片(Voyager Golden Record)的项目。这是美国宇航局(NASA)与外星人沟通的尝试之一。所以你会认为这种事完全符合他的专长。通常你不会被要求去设计一个能持续1万年的东西。那是已记录的人类历史跨度的两倍。联邦政府确实在召唤他来帮助保护1万年未来的人类。废物隔离试点厂，简称WIPP，是经国会
by Congress in 1979. The thinking was, the US ought to have a safe place to put radioactive byproducts from nuclear weapons manufacturing and nuclear power plants. And a quick refresher, even though you don't see radiation, and you might not feel its effects right away, exposure to radioactive materials can destroy your body at a molecular level. It can leave burns, it can cause cancer, it can even mutate your DNA. And the thing about radioactivity is that it is very spreadable.
于1979年下令建立的。当时的设想是，美国应该有一个安全的地方来存放核武器制造和核电站产生的放射性副产品。简单复习一下，尽管你看不见辐射，而且你可能不会立刻感受到它的影响，但接触放射性材料会在分子水平上摧毁你的身体。它会留下烧伤，引发癌症，甚至会使你的DNA发生突变。而放射性最可怕的一点在于，它极易扩散。
Say you've got a tool that touched a piece of plutonium. Now that tool is radioactive. And say a worker was wearing protective gloves while using that tool, chances are those gloves are radioactive too. The waste isolation pilot plant was designed to store all of this stuff and keep us all safe from it. The website is in New Mexico. Deep in the desert, about 26 miles east of Carlsbad.
比方说，你有一个接触过一块钚的工具。现在那个工具就是放射性的。比方说有个工人在使用该工具时戴着防护手套，那么这些手套很有可能也是放射性的。废物隔离试点厂的设计目的就是为了储存所有这些东西，并保护我们免受其害。这个废料场位于新墨西哥州。位于沙漠深处，在卡尔斯巴德(Carlsbad)以东约26英里处。
It's a really cool place. It reminded me of kind of the headquarters of Spectre or Doctrineau and a James Bond novel because it's a big underground facility filled with technicians and coveralls and it's all color coded, depending on what they did. John saw the website in person when he accepted the imitation from Sandia Labs to go be a part of the big group think on designing 10,000 year warning for the place. How could you turn it down? This was in 1991. So the workers took John into an elevator shaft, and they go down about a half a mile beneath the surface,
这是一个非常酷的地方。它让我想起了一种詹姆斯·邦德小说里“魔鬼党”(Spectre)或“杜克诺”(Doctrineau)总部的感觉，因为它是一个巨大的地下设施，里面到处都是身穿连体工作服的技术人员，而且都是根据他们所做的工作进行颜色编码的。约翰亲眼看到了这个废料场，当时他接受了桑迪亚实验室的邀请，去参加那个旨在为该地点设计1万年警示标志的大型智囊团。你怎么能拒绝呢？那是1991年。于是工人们带着约翰走进电梯井，他们向下深入地下约半英里，
and that's where John saw these enormous caverns. They've carved out this repository in basically a salt deposit, a salt deposit, 200 million years old, and we think of salt as white, but this salt, for reasons I don't understand, was kind of a salmone pink color. So the walls of this place were all crystalline with this sort of shot through with these hues of salmon and pink and orange. So it was actually
正是在那里，约翰看到了这些巨大的洞穴。他们在基本上是盐矿层的地方开凿了这个储藏库，这是一个有2亿年历史的盐矿层，我们通常认为盐是白色的，但这种盐由于某种我无法理解的原因，呈现出一种三文鱼般的粉红色。所以这个地方的壁上到处都是晶体，夹杂着三文鱼粉和粉红以及橙色的色调。所以它实际上
quite beautiful. All this radioactive stuff will all be loaded into thousands of oil drums and packed into these caverns. And then this underground chamber will be sealed up and left alone. Years will pass and those years will become decades and those decades will become centuries. And centuries will roll into millennia. And people above ground will come and go, cultures will rise and fall. And all the while, below the surface, the salt will do what salt does with the right temperature and pressure. It will slowly creep, making that cave full of waste, smaller and smaller and smaller, until the salt swallows up all those oil drums, crushing them, and tome in them. And so they're solidified in the Earth's crust.
相当美丽。所有这些放射性废料都将被装进数千个油桶中，并塞进这些洞穴里。然后这个地下室将被密封并被置之不理。岁月流逝，那些年将变成几十年，几十年将变成几个世纪。而几个世纪将汇入千年。地面上的人们来来去去，文化兴衰更迭。与此同时，在地表之下，盐将在适宜的温度和压力下做盐该做的事。它会缓慢蠕动，使那个装满废料的洞穴变得越来越小，直到盐吞噬掉所有的油桶，将它们压碎，并把它们埋葬在其中。于是它们在地壳中固化了。
It will be these gloves and these tools and these little bits from bombs that we made. All-store radioactive, poisonous, for more than 200,000 years. Basically, forever. Storing something dangerous safely, forever forever is a huge design problem. In fact, the jury is still out on whether they solve the basics of the storage problem at all. In February of 2014, a leak was detected that exposed several workers to low levels of radiation and WIP has been closed since.
这些手套、这些工具以及我们制造的炸弹留下的残渣都将存在于此。它们将一直保持放射性、剧毒，持续20万年以上。基本上，永远。将危险物品安全地永远储存下去，这是一个巨大的设计难题。事实上，对于他们是否真正解决了储存问题的基础，各方仍然争论不休。2014年2月，人们检测到了一次泄漏，导致数名工人受到低水平辐射，自那以后WIPP就一直处于关闭状态。
The Department of Energy now predicts that it could be up to three years before Whip is fully operational again. We know these facts because we can look it up and read the news in a shared language. But the problem that John Lomburg was brought out to New Mexico to solve was not about communicating the danger of Whip to people today. He wanted to figure out how to tell people millennia from now that this place is dangerous. When John Lomburg arrived in New Mexico, he met the teammates he be collaborating with. There were biologists, linguists, astrophysicists, there was
能源部现在预测，WIPP可能需要长达三年的时间才能完全恢复运营。我们知道这些事实，是因为我们可以用一种共同的语言去查阅和阅读新闻。但约翰·隆堡被请到新墨西哥州去解决的问题，并不是向今天的人们传达WIPP的危险性。他想弄清楚如何告诉几千年后的人们，这个地方是危险的。当约翰·隆堡抵达新墨西哥州时，他遇到了将与他合作的队友。那里有生物学家、语言学家、天体物理学家，还有
science fiction writer Gregory Benford and he would be the archaeologist. This is Maureen Kaplan. And archaeologist with the consulting firm ERG. Do you remember what you thought of the people they got together like when you first saw them? Um, there's like, oh my goodness. She was kind of starstruck. I went to Annamburg. Wait a moment. Aren't the one who did the picture that went off into space in terms of trying to communicate
科幻作家格雷戈里·本福德(Gregory Benford)，他将担任考古学家。这位是莫琳·卡普兰(Maureen Kaplan)。她是咨询公司ERG的一名考古学家。你还记得你对他们凑在一起的那些人有什么看法吗，比如你刚看到他们的时候？嗯，当时就像是，哦天哪。她有点像见了明星一样。我去找了安农堡。等等。难道你不是那个制作了被发射到太空中的图片的人吗，就是为了试图与
with whoever might fall in danger. So I was impressed. After hellos and whatnot, the Sandia folks split all these smarties into two different groups. So they'd have kind of two separate thinking processes. John was in group B, Marine Group A, and then they laid down the ground rules. They told us to assume that we're designing a warning marker for humans. Not aliens, not cyborgs. But for a human being, biologically identical to us,
任何可能陷入危险的人进行沟通。所以我印象深刻。在寒暄和一番客套之后，桑迪亚的人将这群聪明人分成了两个不同的组。这样他们就会有两套独立的思考过程。约翰在B组，莫琳在A组，然后他们定下了基本规则。他们告诉我们，假设我们是在为人类设计一个警告标志。不是为外星人，也不是为赛博格。而是为了一个在生物学上与我们完全相同的人类，
but whose alive 500 or 5,000 or 10,000 years from now, how can you make a message that that human will understand? And why 10,000 years? As far as I could determine the logic seem to be, well, if we told them to design a marker to last 250,000 years, that's clearly a ridiculous and absurd proposition. 10,000 years doesn't sound quite so crazy. So it was, it was just pulled out of the air. In other words, even though this site is going to be radioactive for hundreds of thousands
但他们生活在500年、5,000年或10,000年之后，你该如何制作一条能让那个人类理解的信息？为什么是一万年？据我所能查明的逻辑似乎是，嗯，如果我们让他们设计一个能持续25万年的标志，那显然是一个荒谬而可笑的命题。一万年听起来似乎没有那么疯狂。所以它，它只是凭空捏造出来的。换句话说，尽管这个地方将在成百上千年的时间里
of years, this panel was only responsible for keeping this place sufficiently labeled for humans for the next 10,000 years. Let's get some perspective. Think about where humanity was 10,000 years ago. Back then, there was a hot new technology taking the world by storm. It was called farming before the agricultural revolution human subsisted as gatherer hunters. Biologically we are the same people we were 10,000 years ago. Actually that's true going back
保持放射性，但这个专家小组只负责在未来一万年里为这个地方保持对人类的充分标识。让我们换个角度来看。想想1万年前人类在哪里。在那时，一项风靡全球的炙手可热的新技术诞生了。它叫作农业。在农业革命之前，人类靠采集和狩猎维生。从生物学上讲，我们和1万年前的人是同一种人。事实上，把时间追溯到
over 40,000 years. But culturally we share almost nothing with these people. Definitely not language. Well no, because the linguists tell us that language changes. Language has a half-life, just like radioactive materials. Have a half-life. And this half-life isn't very long. Think about Shakespeare. My cousin West Mullen's name, my fair cousin. A lack what poverty my muse brings forth.
4万多年前也是如此。但在文化上，我们与这些人几乎没有什么共同点。绝对没有共同的语言。噢，不，因为语言学家告诉我们，语言是会变化的。语言有半衰期，就像放射性材料一样。有半衰期。而且这个半衰期并不长。想想莎士比亚。我表弟韦斯特·穆伦的名字，我亲爱的表弟。唉，我的缪斯带来了多么贫乏的东西。
But this dotage of our generals or flows the measure. Some of the words are tough. Bully rook, festinately fleshment, crinquant. Is that how you say that? But you know high schoolers can get through it. Although Shakespeare was only 400 years ago, 4% of 10,000 years. What? Go back to Beowulf.
但我们将军们的这种昏聩超越了限度。有些词很难懂。暴发户(bully rook)、急切地(festinately)、初试锋芒(fleshment)、金光闪闪(crinquant)。是这么念的吗？但你知道高中生们还是能读懂的。尽管莎士比亚生活的年代距今只有400年，占一万年的4%。什么？回到《贝奥武夫》(Beowulf)。
Way God denna. Written in Old English. Say old kunigah,, Yafrunon. It's basically incomprehensible. El and Fremidon. Off-chul-shaving, Shae-Zen-A-Thre-Tum. Yeah, it's like a different language. And I know you can't see this because this is radio, but trust me, it's just as confusing
(古英语诵读声)用古英语写的。说old kunigah，Yafrunon。这基本上是不可理解的。(古英语诵读声)是的，这就像是一种不同的语言。我知道你看不到这些，因为这是广播，但相信我，在书页上也同样令人困惑。
on the written page. You can recognize most of the letters as being part of the English alphabet, but they barely correspond with how we use those letters today. And that's from year 1000, 10% of 10,000 years. There are some languages that are very resistant to change. That is languages that get enshrined in biblical texts and religious texts. Latin, Hebrew, Arabic. But those aren't shore bets either. The oldest written texts go back to ancient Samaria, about 4, Hebrew, Arabic. But those aren't shore bets either. The oldest written texts go back to ancient Samaria, about 4,600 years ago. And those languages are long-sensed dead.
你可以认出大部分字母是英文字母表的一部分，但它们几乎与我们今天使用这些字母的方式不对应。而那是公元1000年的语言，占一万年的10%。有些语言对变化的抵抗力非常强。也就是那些被写入圣经文本和宗教文本中的语言。拉丁语、希伯来语、阿拉伯语。但那些也不是稳操胜券的。最早的书面文本可以追溯到古代苏美尔，大约在4,希伯来语、阿拉伯语。但那些也不是稳操胜券的。最早的书面文本可以追溯到古代苏美尔，大约在4,600年前。而那些语言早已消亡。
And that's not even the halfway mark of our time frame. So both team A and team B at the Whip Brain Storming session realize pretty quickly that every language on the planet today could be gone well before 10,000 years. And how can you start a conversation with somebody that you have no common language with? Both groups weren't sure about this. But then they thought there's gotta be something better than language.
这甚至还不到我们时间框架的一半。因此，WIPP头脑风暴会议上的A组和B组都很快意识到，今天地球上的每一种语言很可能在1万年到来之前就早已消失了。你又怎么能和一个跟你没有任何共同语言的人开始对话呢？两组人对此都没有把握。但后来他们认为，一定有什么东西比语言更好。
Symbols. Symbols, pictures. There are some facial expressions which are pretty universal. Like smiley face. Two dots for eyes, half circle for a mouth. It's happy. Yeah. And take another one for like yuck. Symbol called Mr. Yuck. If you were alive in the 80s, you know this one. It's a logo of a green face with squinty eyes and a stuck-out tongue. The face looks like it's about to be sick. It was designed to be put on cleaning products and other household poisons to let kids know
符号。符号，图片。有一些面部表情是相当通用的。比如笑脸。两个点作眼睛，半个圆圈作嘴巴。代表快乐。对。再拿另一个表情来举例，比如“恶心”。一个叫作“恶心先生”(Mr. Yuck)的符号。如果你在80年代生活过，你就会知道这个。它是一个绿色面孔的标志，眯着眼睛，还吐出舌头。这个脸看起来好像要吐了似的。它的设计初衷是贴在清洁剂和其他家用毒物上，好让孩子们知道
that whatever is inside is going to be horrible for you. And so, thinking along those lines, they considered another logo, which they thought might be universal. Actually, Carl Sagan proposed it. Sagan couldn't make the panel, but he sent in a letter saying this whole marker problem was easy. You just need the right symbol, and he sent in a letter saying this whole marker problem was easy. You just need the right symbol, and he knew just the one. The Scull and Crossbones. The Jolly Roger. Death incarnate.
里面装的东西对你来说会糟糕透顶。因此，沿着这个思路，他们考虑了另一个他们认为可能是通用的标志。事实上，卡尔·萨根提出了这个建议。萨根没能出席专家小组的会议，但他发来了一封信，称整个标记问题很简单。你只需要正确的符号，并发来了一封信，称整个标记问题很简单。你只需要正确的符号，而且他正好知道该用哪一个。骷髅头和交叉骨。快乐罗杰(Jolly Roger)。死神的化身。
Well, do you know where the Scull and Crossbones came from? No, no, I don't. The earliest uses of it are in religious paintings and sculptures from Middle Ages, where at the foot of the cross where Jesus is crucified, there's a skull with two bones in the shape of a cross, not an X, the shape of a cross. And it's Adam's skull, and the bones are the symbol of the resurrection. So instead of it being a symbol of death, it was a symbol of resurrection and rebirth. But fast forward a couple of centuries. There's a lot of trade going on, merchant ships traveling to and fro. And in the ship's log, if a sailor died, the captain would put a little skull and crossbones next to his name. And a lot of the sailors came to associate that symbol with death.
那么，你知道骷髅头和交叉骨是从哪里来的吗？不，不，我不知道。它最早的使用是在中世纪的宗教绘画和雕塑中，在耶稣被钉十字架的十字架底部，有一个带有两根呈十字形交叉的骨头的骷髅，不是X形，是十字形。那是亚当的骷髅，而那些骨头则是复活的象征。因此，它没有成为死亡的象征，而是复活和重生的象征。但把时间快进几个世纪。当时有大量的贸易活动，商船来来往往。如果在航海日志中，有水手死亡，船长就会在他的名字旁边画一个小骷髅和交叉骨。许多水手开始将这个符号与死亡联系起来。
The rebirth part of it was kind of lost, fast forward another century. You've got pirates out marauding on the high seas, they've plundered other boats and stole their cargo. And along the way, some pirates realized they could use a symbol to let their targets know who they were. A branding campaign to terrify their targets into compliance. Yeah, to make clear, we're pirates, and if you don't surrender, we're going to kill
其中重生的部分在某种程度上被遗忘了，再把时间快进一个世纪。海盗在公海上四处掠夺，他们洗劫其他船只并抢夺货物。在这个过程中，一些海盗意识到他们可以使用一个符号来让目标知道他们是谁。这是一场品牌营销活动，旨在用恐惧让目标屈服。是的，为了明确表明，我们是海盗，如果你不投降，我们就会杀死
you. It's your death. But there were actually several different icons that pirates used. For example, a heart with blood dripping out of it. That was a popular pirate flag. And an even more popular symbol was an hourglass. An hourglass? An hourglass meant if you don't surrender in a certain amount of time, we're going to kill
你。这就是你的死期。但实际上有几个不同的海盗图标。例如，一颗流着血的心脏。那是很受欢迎的海盗旗。还有一个更受欢迎的符号是沙漏。沙漏？沙漏意味着如果你不在一定时间内投降，我们就会把你们
you all. So the hourglass for a while was the most feared pirate symbol. But then one of the logos got famous. In 1720, a pirate named Calico Jack Rackham was captured and put on trial. In the legal proceedings, it came out that two of the pirates in Calico Jack's crew were women and that one of them was pregnant with Calico Jack's child.
统统杀死。所以沙漏有一段时间是最令人畏惧的海盗符号。但后来其中一个标志出名了。1720年，一个名叫卡利科·杰克·拉克姆(Calico Jack Rackham)的海盗被捕并接受审判。在法律诉讼过程中，人们爆出一个消息：卡利科·杰克手下的船员中有两名是女性，其中一人还怀着卡利科·杰克的孩子。
This was the tabloid scandal of the day, and everyone in England was reading about this trial. Anyway, it just so happened that Calico Jack's symbol was the Jolly Roger, though in his case, the bones were replaced with a pair of cross swords. Quick aside, the name Jolly Roger is probably an English corruption of the French Joli Rouge
这是当时的八卦丑闻，英国的所有人都在阅读关于这场审判的报道。无论如何，恰好卡利科·杰克的符号就是“快乐罗杰”，尽管在他的案子里，骨头被换成了一对交叉的剑。顺便说一句，“快乐罗杰”(Jolly Roger)这个名字可能是英语对法语“Joli Rouge”的误传，
or pretty red because the original pirate flags were red, not black. After that trial, the skull and crossbones started showing up on book covers. Treasure Island kind of novels. The skull and crossbones was permeating culture as a symbol of danger. Jump ahead to the late 1800s. Die factories in Germany started using the Skull and Crossbones as a symbol for poison.
意为“漂亮的红色”，因为最初的海盗旗是红色的，而不是黑色的。那次审判之后，骷髅头和交叉骨开始出现在书籍封面上。《金银岛》(Treasure Island)类的小说。骷髅头和交叉骨作为危险的象征开始渗透到文化中。快进到19世纪末。德国的染料厂开始使用骷髅头和交叉骨作为毒药的象征。
Half a century later. The Nazis adopted it as the symbol for their SS death-head divisions. So the Skull and Crossbones came to be associated with danger and death around the world, but it didn't become a universal, not really. Think about what's happened with the Skull and Crossbones in the last 20, 30 years. It's gone mainstream. Now you'll see it on kids' book bags, on
半个世纪后。纳粹将其采纳为其党卫军骷髅师(SS death-head divisions)的标志。因此，骷髅头和交叉骨在世界各地开始与危险和死亡联系在一起，但它并没有成为一个真正的通用符号，并不是真的。想想在过去的20、30年里，骷髅头和交叉骨发生了什么变化。它已经主流化了。现在你会看到它出现在儿童的书包上、
lunzies for infants. You can even buy water bottles with the skull and crossbones. So much for the whole poison thing. And the original meaning as it pertains to Adam and the resurrection is long gone. The lesson that we took from this is that symbols can change. Iconographical drift happens. And we haven't even touched on cultural interpretation. Like there's a candy company in Mexico called Laca Trina and they're logo, the logo that goes on the packaging
婴儿连体衣上。你甚至可以买到带有骷髅头和交叉骨的水瓶。所谓的毒药标志也就不过如此了。而它与亚当和复活相关的最初含义早已荡然无存。我们从中得到的教训是，符号是会改变的。图像学漂移(Iconographical drift)是会发生的。而且我们甚至还没有涉及文化解读。比如墨西哥有一家叫作Laca Trina的糖果公司，他们的标志，印在包装上的
for their sweets is a skull. And so to bring us back to the website in New Mexico. The two teams of smart people at Whip realized that symbols couldn't be trusted to mean the same things over time. So next idea? We could tell a little story using stick figures. Visual storytelling. The stick figure that like any five-year-old could draw.
糖果包装上的标志就是一个骷髅。因此，把我们带回新墨西哥州的废料场。WIPP那两组聪明人意识到，随着时间的推移，不能指望符号始终保持相同的含义。那么下一个主意呢？我们可以用火柴人讲一个小故事。视觉叙事。那种任何五岁小孩都能画出来的火柴人。
Yeah, a circle on top, a trunk, two arms, and two legs. Why? Well, there are two things that seem to be universal in human art. One is a stick figure. And you find them all drawn on the walls of the caves and the cave paintings that are 25,000 years old, which by the way may be the only piece of graphic art surviving for more than 10,000 years. That is art from which we can draw meaning.
对，上面一个圆圈，一个躯干，两只胳膊和两条腿。为什么？嗯，在人类艺术中有两样东西似乎是普遍存在的。一个是火柴人。你会发现它们都被画在洞穴的墙壁上，那是拥有25,000年历史的洞穴壁画，顺便说一句，这可能是唯一能够延续1万多年而幸存下来的平面艺术。那是我们可以从中汲取意义的艺术。
And John says there's another convention that is universal. A sequence of events. First this happens, then this happens, and then this happens. So like a narrative, a story. A narrative, a storyboard, a comic strip. You just find it everywhere. And in fact, you can even define a symbol using stick figures. Check it out. Let's do a simple comic strip. So first frame, you put the small child.
约翰说，还有另一个普遍存在的惯例。一系列事件。先发生这个，然后发生这个，再发生这个。就像叙事一样，一个故事。叙事、故事板、连环画。你在到处都能找到它们。事实上，你甚至可以用火柴人来定义一个符号。来看看吧。我们来做一个简单的连环画。所以第一格，你放一个小孩子。
And the child isn't from a small plant, a sapling. Second frame, that child is a little bit bigger now, and the sapling behind him has grown a little bit. And next to the child is a barrel. And on that barrel is the symbol for radiation, the Trefoil symbol. to the child is a barrel. And on that barrel is the symbol for radiation, the Trefoil symbol. And the child is touching that barrel. Go to the third frame, you got a full grown big old tree, you got a child that is now an adult, a human being, except the person is lying on the ground, presumably dead, exes over their eyes, frowny mouth. And the barrel now with the Trefoil symbol is open. And so clearly, the idea is,
而孩子不是来自一棵小植物，而是一棵树苗。第二格，那个孩子现在稍微大了一点，他身后的树苗也稍微长大了。在孩子旁边是一个桶。那个桶上有辐射的符号，也就是三叶形符号。在孩子旁边是一个桶。那个桶上有辐射的符号，也就是三叶形符号。而那个孩子正在触摸那个桶。转到第三格，你有一棵长成的大树，你有一个现在已经成年的人类，除了这个人正躺在地上，大概已经死了，眼睛上画着叉号，嘴呈悲伤的下垂状。而那个带有三叶形符号的桶现在打开了。所以很显然，这个想法是，
don't touch anything with the Trefoil symbol, or at least not a barrel. Of course you read it from right to left, and it's a totally different story. The old guy who is sick, discovers the fountain of youth, and he's reborn. Okay, all is not lost.
不要触摸任何带有三叶形符号的东西，或者至少不要触摸桶。当然，如果你从右往左读，它就是一个完全不同的故事。那个生病的老头发现了青春之泉，然后他重生了。好吧，并非无可救药。
Maybe you could use arrows. Arrows are universal or maybe you could situate the various comic scripts in a sequence that you can only see sequentially based on how they're arranged in space. So, I don't know, maybe it's possible to create a universally recognizable warning sign that way. But really, regardless of whatever symbol we're trying to come up with or whatever story
也许你可以用箭头。箭头是通用的，或者你也可以把各种连环画按顺序排列，只有根据它们在空间中的排列顺序才能按顺序看到它们。所以，我不知道，也许用这种方式创造一个普遍可识别的警告标志是可能的。但说实话，不管我们试图想出什么符号，或者我们试图讲什么故事，
that we're trying to tell, can we actually build something, make something, like a physical, tangible thing that can last 10,000 years? The brainstormers at WIP thought about building something from solid gold. Well, what's going to happen? They're going to get stolen. Moring Kaplan, the archaeologist, who group realized the same thing?? They're going to get stolen. Moring Kaplan, the archaeologist, who group realized the same thing? The medals were going to get recycled.
我们真的能建造某样东西、制造某样东西吗，比如一个能够持续1万年的实体、有形的东西？WIPP的头脑风暴者们曾考虑用纯金建造某样东西。嗯，会发生什么？它们会被偷走。考古学家莫琳·卡普兰，其所在的小组意识到了同样的事情？？它们会被偷走。考古学家莫琳·卡普兰，其所在的小组意识到了同样的事情？这些金属会被回收利用。
So no bronze, no aluminum, that basically leaves you with rocks. And rocks can erode. And who knows, a giant monolith could be useful to some future desert person. You could, you know, just tip it over on its side and then you have a foundation for your house. Here is the critical moment where all the obvious choices have been exhausted. Language, symbols, and storyboards weren't going to cut it. And here's where plans for the website start getting really wacky. There was this one guy in Maureen's group, named Mike Brill. Mike Brill was a landscape architect.
所以不能用青铜，不能用铝，基本上只剩下岩石了。而岩石是会侵蚀的。谁知道呢，一个巨大的独石可能会对未来的某个沙漠居民有用。你知道的，你可以把它推倒，然后你就有建造房屋的地基了。这是最关键的时刻，所有显而易见的选择都已穷尽。语言、符号和故事板都行不通。正是在这里，WIPP废料场的计划开始变得真正离奇起来。莫琳小组里有一个名叫迈克·布里尔(Mike Brill)的家伙。迈克·布里尔是一位景观设计师。
And an artist, Brill has since passed away. But Marine remembers in their group, Brill had this revelation. You don't actually need to transmit information into the future. All you need to do is make somebody scared of being in that place. He was trying to sculpt the landscape such that it in itself gave a warning to people who were coming there and he was thinking on a massive scale and a scale greater than I'd ever imagined. Like one drawing, which might called the landscape of thorns,
同时也是一位艺术家，布里尔此后已经去世。但莫琳记得在他们的团队中，布里尔有了这样一个顿悟。你实际上并不需要将信息传递到未来。你所需要做的就是让某人对身处那个地方感到害怕。他试图塑造景观，使其本身就能向来到那里的人发出警告，而且他思考的规模是巨大的，是我从未想象过的规模。比如一幅画，迈克称之为刺之景观(landscape of thorns)，
a drawing of these huge needles. Sharp, pointed, angular, jutting up from the ground. You know, the earth itself became a cactus. Make the land itself ominous and impassable. But... The last thing you want to do is draw people to see this incredible work of art. It's you got to see this thing. It's a half mile of these giant spikes. What the hell is it? So somebody builds a hotel for them to
画的是这些巨大的针刺。从地面上突兀地伸出，尖锐、锋利、棱角分明。你知道的，地球本身变成了一片仙人掌。让土地本身变得不祥且无法通行。但……你最不想做的事情就是吸引人们来看这件令人难以置信的艺术品。你得来看看这个东西。这是一长达半英里的巨型尖刺。这到底是什么鬼东西？于是有人为他们建造了一家酒店以供
stay in and they decide to dig a well for water and there you are. You've just caused exactly what you're trying to avoid. When all was said and done both groups submitted their proposals but Sandy Alabs found most of the ideas a little too pie in the sky. Here's Roger Nelson, the chief scientist at the Department of Energy's Carlsbad Field Office, which owns and operates WIP. If we build any markers, they need to be constructed at a reasonable cost, because it's just not right to ask real current generations of real people today
住宿，他们决定挖一口水井取水，然后你就中招了。你刚好引发了你极力想要避免的事情。说到底，两个小组都提交了各自的提案，但桑迪亚实验室发现大多数想法都有点过于不切实际。这位是罗杰·内尔森(Roger Nelson)，能源部卡尔斯巴德现场办公室的首席科学家，该办公室拥有并运营WIPP。如果我们建造任何标记，它们都需要以合理的成本建造，因为要求当今现实世界的真正一代人
to sacrifice through their tax dollars or whatever to invest in protecting a hypothetical intruder into some very far future from a risk for which there's likely no harm to result. In fact, the panel that met to figure out the whip-marker system was actually not the first instance of thinkers being brought together to consider how to communicate the dangers of nuclear waste over time. There was one such meeting in 1981 for the Yucca Mountain project, which was eventually scrapped. And the Yucca Mountain project had probably the craziest idea proposed, and even though
通过他们的纳税等方式作出牺牲，来投资保护某个遥远未来的假想闯入者，使其免受可能根本不会造成伤害的风险，这是很不合理的。事实上，那个开会研究WIPP标记系统的专家小组并不是思想家们聚在一起探讨如何长期传达核废料危险性的第一例。1981年曾为尤卡山项目(Yucca Mountain project)召开过这样一次会议，该项目最终被废弃了。而尤卡山项目可能提出了最疯狂的想法，尽管
it was never suggested for Whip, it's become the 99PI in-house favorite method of communicating with people 10,000 years in the future. In fact, it's probably the reason why we're doing this story at all. Call it the Raycat solution. My hands down favorite approach came from these two European philosophers, Francois Besteid and Palo Fabri.
它从未被提议用于WIPP，但它已经成为99PI内部最喜爱的与1万年未来人类沟通的方法。事实上，这可能就是我们做这个故事的原因。称之为“射线猫方案”(The Raycat solution)。我毫无疑问最喜欢的方案来自这两位欧洲哲学家，弗朗索瓦·贝斯特(Francois Besteid)和保罗·法布里(Palo Fabri)。
It goes like this. The two of them got thinking that the most durable thing that humanity has ever made is culture, religion, folklore, belief systems, sure they morph over time, but an essential message can get pulled through. And so Besteid and Fabri said, here's what we're going to do. We're going to genetically engineer a species of cat that changes color in the presence of radiation. Then we'd release them out into the wild to become feline-geiger counters.
它是这样的。他们两个开始思考，人类创造的最持久的东西是文化、宗教、民间传说、信仰体系，当然它们会随着时间而变形，但核心信息可以被传递下来。因此，贝斯特和法布里说，我们要这么做。我们将通过基因工程改造一种猫，这种猫在有辐射存在时会变色。然后我们将它们释放到野外，让它们成为猫科盖革计数器。
And that's just step number one. Step number two, we will create an entire system of folklore about these cats. So we will sing songs about them. We will draw pictures of them. We will tell stories about them. And like any good story, there's a more. That when you see the cats turn color, run far, far away.
而这仅仅是第一步。第二步，我们将围绕这些猫创造一整套民间传说。所以我们要唱关于它们的歌。我们要画关于它们的画。我们要讲关于它们的故事。就像任何好故事一样，还有更多内容。那就是当你看到猫变色时，赶快逃得远远的。
Don't change color, kitty, keep your color free, stay up in night black. The radiation, the change in the flies, you can kill them, that's a fact. The radiation, whatever that is, is something we don't want. Once this recap folklore becomes embedded into our culture, the knowledge it contains can evolve with us, even as our language shifts. 10,000 years from now, these songs and these stories may sound incomprehensible to us, but as long as they communicate this idea, that it's not safe to be where the cats change colors. We will have done our job.
别变色，小猫咪，保持你本来的颜色，留在黑夜般的安宁中。辐射，随之而来的变异，能杀死它们，这是事实。辐射，不管那是什么，都是我们不想要的。一旦这个射线猫的民间传说根植于我们的文化中，它所包含的知识就能与我们一起演变，即使我们的语言发生变化。1万年后，这些歌曲和故事在我们听来可能无法理解，但只要它们传达了这样一个理念：猫变色的地方是不安全的。我们就完成了我们的使命。
May the Raycats keep us safe. The plan that Sandia Labs decided to move forward with does not involve Raycats, sadly, or a landscape of thorns. It doesn't even involve the skull and crossbones. One of the conceptual designs includes a big berm, a 30 feet high, earthen construction around the footprint of the repository. That's Roger Nelson again, the chief scientist overseeing Whip. At the end of the day, the powers that be decided to go with solutions
愿射线猫保佑我们安全。桑迪亚实验室决定推进的计划并不涉及射线猫，遗憾的是，也没有刺之景观。它甚至不涉及骷髅头和交叉骨。概念设计之一包括一个大堤(berm)，一个围绕储藏库占地面积的30英尺高的土质建筑。这位又是罗杰·内尔森，监督WIPP的首席科学家。归根结底，当权者决定采用那些
that the panelists had pretty much cast aside. They're marking the area with large granite monuments. Large granite monuments at each corner in the middle and several buried libraries. There will be information in seven languages, the six languages of the UN, Arabic, Chinese, English, French, Russian, Spanish, and also Navajo. Because it's the most prevalent indigenous language of the area.
专家小组成员基本上已经抛弃的解决方案。他们用大型花岗岩纪念碑来标记这个区域。在每个角落、中间以及几个埋藏的图书馆处都有大型花岗岩纪念碑。那里将提供七种语言的信息，即联合国六种官方语言：阿拉伯语、中文、英语、法语、俄语、西班牙语，以及纳瓦霍语。因为它是该地区最盛行的本土语言。
The plan is still being finalized. But keep in mind, we're talking about protecting people that our great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great grandkids, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, great, I read about this town called Talibas, a small predominantly African-American community about our hour and a half south of Tampa, Florida. In the 1960s, a burrillian processing plant was set up in the middle of town. The plant manufactured components for nuclear bombs and also built pieces of a Hubble space telescope. Anyway, it turned out that this plant was never very good about dealing with its waste. Burrillian dust and other toxins made their way into the town's ground water. And talovast had always gotten its water from shallow wells.
该计划仍在敲定中。但请记住，我们谈论的是保护那些我们的曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾格外的后代。我读过关于一个叫作塔拉巴斯(Talabas)的小镇的报道，这是一个主要由非裔美国人组成的小社区，位于佛罗里达州坦帕市以南大约一个半小时车程的地方。在20世纪60年代，镇中心建立了一家铍加工厂。该工厂为核弹制造零部件，还制造了哈勃太空望远镜的部件。无论如何，事实证明这家工厂在处理废料方面从来都不太擅长。铍尘和其他毒素进入了该镇的地下水。而塔拉巴斯一直以来都是从浅水井获取水源。
Residents started noticing that a lot of people were getting diagnosed with cancer and other diseases, including buriliosis, which you get from exposure to burilium. Talovast filed a lawsuit against the company that owns the plant, Lockheed Martin, and Lockheed spent years dragging out the lawsuit. Now the reason I bring this up is because Lockheed Martin happens to be the parent company of San Bia National Labs, the corporation that runs the website over in New Mexico. And this case at Tallahbast is hardly unique. There are literally thousands of towns across the United States.
居民们开始注意到，许多人被诊断出患有癌症和其他疾病，包括铍中毒(beriliosis)，这是接触铍后会患上的疾病。塔拉巴斯对拥有该工厂的公司洛克希德·马丁(Lockheed Martin)提起诉讼，而洛克希德花了好几年时间来拖延诉讼。我之所以提起这件事，是因为洛克希德·马丁公司恰好是桑迪亚国家实验室的母公司，而桑迪亚国家实验室正是运营新墨西哥州那个废料场的企业。塔拉巴斯的这个案子绝非孤例。美国各地实际上有成千上万个城镇。
Many of them low income or communities of color that have become contaminated in similar ways. And so the 10,000 year whip marker system feels really noble, but maybe a little misguided. I am all for taking care of people 10,000 years in the future. But I think the best way to do that is to start taking care of people that are alive today. That way there might be humans in 10,000 years. And cats. Don't change color to keep your keep your color, could you stay that pretty grey?
其中许多是低收入或有色人种社区，它们以类似的方式受到了污染。因此，那个1万年的WIPP标记系统感觉非常崇高，但也可能有点被误导了。我完全赞成照顾1万年后的未来人类。但我认为做到这一点的最好方法是开始照顾今天活著的人们。这样一来，1万年后才可能有人类。还有猫。别变色，保持你的颜色，能让那个美丽的灰色保持下去吗？
Don't change color, could you keep your color, could you keep sickness away? Don't change color, could you keep your color, could you please go as if you do? Or go your Luma nest and I, all gonna have to move. 99% Invisible West Produced This Week by Matthew Kielty and Sam Greenspan, with Katie Mingle, Avery Trouffleman and Ney Roman Mars. Special thanks to a bunch of people for helping us with this story, filmmaker Rob Moss, Matt Stroud, and Jordan Oplinger over at The Verge, A. Van Luick at the DOE Carlsbad Field Office, Steve Learner, author of Sacrifice Zones, and Emperor X, aka Chad Methini, for composing the original song, Don't Change Color Kitty, which will be in your travel case, because it's time to move.
别变色，你能保持你的颜色，你能让疾病远离吗？别变色，你能保持你的颜色，你能像平时一样离开吗？或者离开你的卢马内斯和我，大家都得搬家。“99%无形”本周由马修·基尔蒂和萨姆·格林斯潘(Sam Greenspan)制作，凯蒂·明格尔(Katie Mingle)、艾弗里·特劳夫曼(Avery Truffleman)和罗曼·马斯共同参与。特别感谢许多帮助我们完成这个故事的人，包括电影制作人罗伯·莫斯(Rob Moss)、《The Verge》网站的马特·斯特劳德(Matt Stroud)和乔丹·奥普林格(Jordan Oplinger)、能源部卡尔斯巴德现场办公室的A·范·吕克(A. Van Luick)、《牺牲地带》(Sacrifice Zones)一书的作者史蒂夫·勒纳(Steve Learner)，以及皇帝X(Emperor X，又名查德·梅蒂尼 Chad Methini)，他创作了原创歌曲《别变色小猫咪》(Don't Change Color Kitty)，这首歌将出现在你的旅行箱里，因为是时候搬家了。
We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced the offices of ArcSign, an architecture firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. We are a founding member of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the most interesting, innovative sound-rich radio programs in the world. And this week, this week, all the Radio Topia programs are putting out a new episode every single day around the theme, The Long Shadow. Stories where one person or place casts an outsized influence across time and space. In this week on Radio Diaries, The Long shadow of Aisa Carter, speech writer for Governor
我们是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的建筑事务所ArcSign的办公室里制作。我们是PRX旗下“无线电乌托邦”(Radio Topia)的创始成员，这是一个汇集了世界上最有趣、最具创新性、声音丰富的广播节目的集体。而本周，本周“无线电乌托邦”的所有节目都在围绕“长影”(The Long Shadow)这一主题每天推出一集新节目。这些故事讲述了一个人或一个地方如何在时间和空间上投下巨大的影响。本周在《无线电日记》(Radio Diaries)中，将讲述埃萨·卡特(Aisa Carter)的长影，他是州长
George Wallace who penned the infamous segregation now, segregation forever speech. Well, I am just an old rebel, recognizing all I am, and I don't want no part for nothing that I've done. This is Aisa Carter. May God bless you, and I thank you for listening. And that's the last time I ever saw Ace of Cardinals. He just vanished. I keep dropped off the face of Earth. And this week on Love and Radio, a woman ready to leave everything on Earth behind to set up a permanent settlement on Mars. I think there are probably a lot of things that all miss my family and pizza and beer especially.
乔治·华莱士(George Wallace)的演讲稿撰写人，曾撰写了那篇臭名昭著的“现在隔离，永远隔离”的演讲。好吧，我只是个老反叛者，承认我的一切，我不想为我做过的事承担任何责任。这位是埃萨·卡特。愿上帝保佑你们，谢谢你们的收听。那是我最后一次见到埃萨·卡特。他直接消失了。我一直觉得他从地球上消失了。本周在《爱与广播》(Love and Radio)中，讲述了一位准备抛弃地球上的一切去火星建立永久定居点的女性。我想可能有很多事情我会想念我的家人，尤其是披萨和啤酒。
If nobody's actually read about it or looked at the website, I think it kind of sounds still crazy and I think most people think that I'm like getting sucked into some weird cults. The Long Shaddy. Every day week, a new episode from a member of the Radio Topia group, you do not want to miss it. In fact, I'm going to subscribe to them all and then chain them all together into one gigantic block of awesome radio. You can find all the radio topia shows at radiotopia.fm
如果人们没有真正读过相关内容或看过这个网站，我想这听起来依然很疯狂，而且我认为大多数人会认为我像是被卷入了什么奇怪的邪教。长影。每周每天都有来自“无线电乌托邦”成员的新节目，你绝对不想错过。事实上，我要订阅所有的节目，然后把它们串联成一个巨大的精彩广播块。你可以在 radiotopia.fm 找到所有“无线电乌托邦”的节目，
or search for us in iTunes. You can follow along with the various exploits of this show on Twitter, Facebook and Tumblr if you want the full song Don't Change Color Kitty by Emperor X. You have to go to 99pi.org Radio Tepio from PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者在iTunes中搜索我们。如果你想要皇帝X的完整歌曲《别变色小猫咪》，你可以在推特、脸书和Tumblr上关注本节目的各种动态。你必须访问 99pi.org 来自PRX的无线电乌托邦。这个节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。